démettant de tous qui constate accepte
comment cette réunion de plusieurs
ministres l'affection constate accès
nous conteste comment total d'environ
mille soucis constate mac c'est nous
qu'on croit de moins en moins nuisible à
la fois physique comme vincent aux sims
à cette situation il ya plus de quinze
comme au concours de tango des
metronautes l'hymne tentative histoire
de vivre je suis dit qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'il m'arrive de la sécurité
[Musique]
dekel garnements se plaisent à terme
pendant l'impro ça c'est de l'impromptu
totalement d'autant que justement
parlant d'un pointu je sais que tous les
deux vous avez un point commun c'est une
passion immodérée pour l'improvisation
je me trompe pas ah non absolument pas
ces mêmes l'improvisation c'est un mot
qui est un peu réducteur je dirais c'est
de la liberté ii c'est la musique de
l'instant pas la cdu momentanée et je
défends ça parce que sort le crochet en
promo je vends un disque normal tu fais
ce qu'il ya sur le dise je pense que les
artistes ont trop prise se plie la de
s'enfermer dans des sphères
d'interprétation je pense qu'à mission
de l'artiste et de ses d'égayer de
rendre vivant le moment donc d'inviter à
la fête des c2 de créer des petits liens
de connivence avec les gens présents si
c'est plus jeune plus vieux et après
voilà il ya déjà vous dire c'est
improvisé s'est jamais vraiment
totalement improvisée je pense qu'après
vise à sion c'est le domaine des dieux
des cieux c'est la création mais ça
arrive parfois quand on est chaude on
est presque au niveau quoi on après est
utile et si c'est ça nous voilà réunis
ici là d'ailleurs dans cette région la
région centre val de loire
vous en êtes pas originaires tous les
deux toi tu es arrivé il ya une dizaine
d'années je me trompe pas et c'est ça
vous plaît plus qu'est ce qui t'a amené
ici moi je cherchais un endroit ouvert
pas trop loin de paris et je pense
m'exiler de ma région natale l'alsace
aussi et tout est
donc je visite est un peu là où mes
tournées m'emmener et puis je me suis
retrouvé accueilli ici
en fait c'est lui à peine de 2 3 ans où
j'étais installé ici rend prendre
facilement et donc me retrouve à la
brocante du 15 août a toréé là il ya ma
voisine qui était ma chorale qui vient
me voir qui me fait bon pierre notre
chef de choeur 120 est ce que ça te
dirait de reprendre la chorale de torre
un quart d'heure après il ya le maire de
torreilles qui vient me dire ah ben
autre intervenant musical de l'école et
il s'en va est ce que ça te dirait de
reprendre la musique à l'école et puis
après c'est que ça soit que ça soit
juste c'est un petit peu plus récent
dans ton installation ici à ces super
frais ça ait moins de trois mois
donc j'ai appelé pierre je peux venir
chez toi quelques jours quelques
semaines mais évidemment on parle du
confinement valant parle de ça dont je
suis venu là et puis on avait le droit
de sortir une petite heure par jour je
partais faire mon footing 1 et puis j'ai
découvert un peu les sentiers je tombé
amoureux de la région j'ai senti qu'il y
avait quelque chose en faisant quelques
recherches je me suis rendu compte qu'il
y avait un océan ici à 200 mille ans qui
avait des chasseurs cueilleurs là sur
les coteaux j'ai senti qu'il me manque
quelque chose de très intéressant ici et
je me suis enregistré une petite vidéo
avant de rentrer à paris où je me devais
me parler je me dis mec t'as un mois
pour revenir mais toi ici six mois un an
au vert on attend de voir que la
situation
comment ça va évoluer profites en pour
composer pour enregistrer un album phare
avant c'était projet mais je peux pas
rester à paris comme ça c'est pas
possible
donc c'est ce que je suis en train de
faire 1 45 jours après j'étais revenu
voilà et puis et puis je me mets en
place mais petit à petit si mais je suis
ouvert moi je suis en voilà je suis au
vert je sais quoi je te comprends
totalement parce que s'il ya bien
quelque chose que je ressens depuis le
début de la joie c'est qu'il ya une
ambiance particulière ici du côté de
thorey notamment pour les artistes
qu'est ce qui explique ça il ya de
l'espace donc les gens respirent et je
pense que c'est ça que tu remarques
contrairement aux grandes villes mais
aussi cosmopolite qu'elle soit soit
elles sont souvent des abominations
écologique où les gens sont stress et
moi je le sens beaucoup plus calme
depuis que tu as depuis là je me sens
bien que ça arrive et est vraiment plus
qu'un tiers ouais
non mais non là il est des noms il est
vide et bien posée non c'est chouette
s'associent les pires là ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que après le concert
avec tt ce soir le cam a raté voudra pu
repartir d'ici vous allez le garder avec
vous il connaît il y en a bien besoin de
gens comme lui aussi à montreuil et puis
voilà mais je pense qu'il connaît puis
pourra revenir quand ils veulent et
bienvenu après tout simplement plus
merci merci à toi résidence et avoue
renversant big up c'est tonton djidji
dans la place avec clairement bla on est
là on en place une pour le pana mme
belleville longtemps et aussi du cap à
strasbourg